- Little ones!
Yeah, oh my god, I want them all (laughs).
Hi little guy.
Hello.
I'm dying, I can't even
concentrate on what you're saying.
(light music)
(Emma squeals)
I'm here with BuzzFeed, I'm
playing with tiny cute kittens.
My day is made.
We designed for Belle this
ring that would sit on
her little finger.
The costume designer saw
that I had one which my mom
had given to me, and she
was like, can I design
one for Belle?
Because Belle's mother dies
when she's really young.
My mom is still alive
and healthy and well,
just as a side-note.
Anyway, I was really proud
of the ring and thought it
was so beautiful that I
asked if I could keep one,
and they said I could.
Do you want to come down?
Is this a little high for you?
Oh no, you kind of want to stay.
Okay, you go here, you stay there,
and you can come down here.
(upbeat music)
I just wanted to make
sure that we stayed true
to the original.
So when Kevin Kline was
gonna make Maurice less
kind of like the inventor,
and he wasn't gonna have
that as his story anymore,
I was like well could we
use that for Belle?
And so we made Belle this
inventor who invents this
washing machine, so that
she can sit and read
while it's doing her washing.
This one's chasing its
own shadow, literally.
This is too much.
(light music)
I would want her to
know that she is a force
to be reckoned with and,
never to underestimate
her own power.
Sometimes particularly
young girls feel like their
voice doesn't matter,
and what they have to say
doesn't really matter
and, I think I would want
her to know that it does.
Oh, look at the rose pedals, look.
Pretty rose pedals.
(light music)
So many times.
When people have told me
that I can't do something,
it's gonna be too hard, or whatever else,
I try to use that as motivation.
Sometimes someone telling
you that you won't
be able to do something.
I'm like oh you don't
know what you just did.
Oh it's its shadow again.
Too cute.
(light music)
In my imagining, she opens
the library that's in
the castle, and she
turns it into a school,
and a public library, which she runs.
I love that all of these
guys are crazy and this one
is just chill.
(light music)
Yes, they share the love of books.
Hermione and Belle are like
perfect head and heart girls.
They have both.
They're super smart, but they
also have this incredible
empathy, and compassion,
and ability to see
kind of beyond things,
and be non-judgemental.
(light music)
When we completed the final
dance at the end of the movie,
I had the sound guys play
Happy, and Kevin Kline
started doing the conga,
and like everyone joined in.
It was the most surreal
thing I've ever seen.
Everyone in costume, in the
Beauty and the Beast ballroom,
doing the conga.
(light music)
We think that we live in
a post-feminist society,
and we do not.
So we're told we don't
need feminism anymore,
that we have the vote,
that like we're all good.
And I think actually that's
incredibly disconcerting
because then, when young
women move into the world
and they realize, oh why am
I not being paid the same?
Why am I being treated differently?
And they start to blame
themselves, because they don't
understand that they're
part of a historic pattern,
they're part of a much larger
system which is kind of
working a little bit against them.
Um, no, I don't want it to be over!
Please don't let it be over.
I never want to leave, I
only want to be into you
by Buzzfeed from now on.
I'm really gonna struggle
to say goodbye to this guy.
Massive shout-out to Best
Friends Animal Society,
who save hundreds, and hundreds,
and hundreds of kittens.
They make sure that
these guys find a home.
This has been the
highlight of my press tour,
without a doubt.
We're peaking right now.
There's nothing that's gonna top this.
(light music)